创作内容给我带来了很多机会，但我每天花在创作上的时间有限。所以我一直在思考如何重新设计我的内容流程，使其更适应AI或得到AI辅助。
另一个我试图解决的问题是，如何让员工在全职工作的同时，尽可能轻松地成为创作者。这就是这个内容机器想法的起源，它就是为了解决这两个问题。
我确实读过你的帖子，很不错。所以它们不像是那种垃圾内容，但现场演示一下吧。我们怎么操作这个过程？
内容机器的第一步叫“神谕”。神谕会扫描我所在的所有渠道最近7天的信息，然后排出一个简短的创意列表。它有一套完整的评分系统来判断什么是一个好的内容爆点，并给出正分。我基本上能得到15个内容爆点。
AI开箱即用时写作能力确实很糟糕。你如何让它不写出垃圾内容？
在我看来，内容机器产出垃圾内容唯一的情况，更多是在面试环节没有分享足够好的想法，而不是AI写出的东西差。
哦，所以你的意思是，其实我们才是垃圾内容制造者。
我的观点是，AI垃圾内容很有趣，因为人们其实是在指着自己说，我不够聪明。
欢迎来到《How I AI》。我是Claire Vale，产品负责人兼AI发烧友，我的使命是帮助你更好地使用这些新工具。今天，我请到了10x公司的Alex Lieberman，他将向我们展示他如何攀登“尴尬之山”，也就是如何用AI在他的公司建立内容机器。你猜怎么着？他没有产出AI垃圾内容。对于任何试图营销公司并获取分发优势的人来说，这是一个很棒的工作流程。我们开始吧。先来听听今天赞助商Firecrawl的广告。如果你在用AI代理构建应用，你可能也遇到了同样的难题。你的代理需要从网络获取数据，但很难找到合适的页面，它们要么藏在JavaScript里，要么被登录墙挡住。Firecrawl是一个网络数据API，可以让代理大规模地搜索、抓取并与网页交互，获得干净、结构化的数据。包括我在内的超过一百万名开发者都在使用它。它是开源的，而且免费起步。别再费力从网上扒数据了，用Firecrawl为你的AI代理和应用提供动力，访问firecrawl.dev，使用代码howiai，今天就能获得1万免费积分。
Alex，我真的很期待这一集，因为我告诉每个人，要成功，尤其是作为白手起家的创业者，你必须做一件事，不是“氛围检查”，而是攀登尴尬之山。你必须发帖。你必须在X上发帖，在LinkedIn上发帖，谈论你自己。我得说，作为一个典型的工程师，我宁愿做任何事，也不愿谈论我的生意。
[笑]
人们对此不会感到惊讶。那么，请告诉我，你是如何开始使用AI的？为什么开始用AI来建立公司的内容引擎？
嗯，首先非常感谢你邀请我。我完全赞同攀登AI尴尬之山。我可能站在完全相反的一边，就是我很乐意变得尴尬，然后尽力多射门，来推销我正在做的事情。因为我相信那些认为“如果你建好了，他们就会来”的人，在这个分发比以往任何时候都重要的世界里，我不认为这一定成立，或者说大多数时候都不成立。所以基本上在10x的背景下，我一直在试图解决两个问题。对于不了解10x的人，它是一家应用AI公司，帮助中型市场和企业公司进行AI转型。我们提供从战略到部署工程的一切服务。第一个问题是，我过去10年一直在网上创作内容，基本上从大学创办Morning Brew时就开始。我认为创作内容给我带来了很多机会，但我每天花在创作上的时间是有限的。比如我会……
假设我25%的时间可以用来做内容。所以我一直在想，怎么最大化利用这25%的时间？我思考了很多的是，如何重新设计我的内容流程，让它
成为原生AI或AI辅助的，同时确保我不会输出那种AI垃圾内容，因为我觉得正是那种内容让很多人对AI产生反感，尤其是在内容创作方面，感觉AI只会吐出一些
非常平庸的东西，听起来和网上说过的其他内容没什么两样。第二是，你知道，我建立的每个企业，无论是媒体公司还是非媒体公司，我认为未来我们需要更多地考虑在业务之上建立媒体公司。
原因是在后AI时代，技术比以往任何时候都更加商品化，商业护城河越来越少，我相信可信的传播渠道就是其中之一。所以，总的来说，我正在构建一个媒体
公司，建立在10X之上，而且我认为，你知道，我会做所有显而易见的事情，比如聘请全职创作者加入员工队伍，聘请写手，我们会有一份通讯，所有这些事情。但我认为没有多少公司会考虑把自己的
员工变成创作者，如果他们想这样做的话。所以我一直在尝试解决的另一个问题是，如何尽最大可能让员工在拥有全职工作的同时轻松成为创作者？这就是
这个内容机器想法的起源，就是为了优化这两个问题。
>> 我喜欢这一点，因为第一，我自己也经历过。你知道，我是TikTok的首席产品官。我经历过这个阶段，我当时想，你知道吗？当我担任这些职位时，作为高管的一部分工作就是
成为公司的营销代言人，你知道，我以前常说在SaaS领域，你不是在买产品，而是在买路线图，我会告诉我的团队，他们买的不是路线图，而是团队，这
就是说他们相信这个团队能够执行愿景，所以他们想通过订阅或参与度或其他方式来押注这个团队。我现在和很多CEO交谈，他们对当前的
营销状况感到不安，现有的渠道回报递减，他们看不到老一套方法真正奏效，我告诉他们每一个人，你们的第一营销渠道应该是你们的员工。所以我喜欢
你在这方面投资。现在我最担心的是，嗯，我也有点，你知道，内容分发引擎，其中包含一些AI。AI开箱即用，在写吸引人的文案方面相当糟糕。而且
我想我们都见过这种情况。我们都对它非常挑剔，但看起来你已经解决了这个问题。所以我很想听听你的流程，你认为AI适合在哪里，不适合在哪里，你如何让它不写出垃圾内容。
>> 是的，完全同意。我在这里有几点想法。我们之前谈过这个，即Lulu Meservey谈到过这个观点，世界上最优秀的作家使用AI是一种遗憾，因为他们限制了自己的上限，所以她的观点是AI会
提高差作家的下限，但会限制优秀作家的上限。我想我同意这个观点，但有一些细微差别。我要说的第一点是，写作和创作内容是一个多步骤的过程，我们会
一步步来看。我认为仅仅说在内容过程的任何部分使用AI都会降低你的上限并不一定正确。我想如果我们说在内容过程的实际起草或编辑部分，
使用AI会降低你的上限，我可以接受，而且我能理解如果你是一位有天赋的作家，属于前1%的作家，基本上依赖一个在互联网整个语料库上训练过的模型，因此按定义会是平均水平的，而
你是一位高于平均水平或杰出的作家，为什么会更差，完全理解。但内容过程有很多部分，我认为其中一些部分你可以使用AI，同时实际上继续提高你的上限，而不是降低它。另一个
点是，我总是考虑替代方案。所以，对于我们10X团队来说，替代方案是，我们稍后可以谈谈我们如何激励人们创作，但在内容机器之前，替代方案就是
人们根本不创作内容。所以这就像，如果我两个选择，让人们围绕他们的专长和他们在工作中所做的事情来创作内容，还是不创作，我当然会每一天都选择第一个。
所以，我能做的是带你了解我如何思考我的内容过程，然后我如何转变它。尽管我们在使用AI做内容的背景下谈论这个，
但我们在10X的观点和我的观点是，你几乎可以用这种流程映射然后重建的方法来处理工作中的任何流程。这只是我所知道的世界。好的。所以，当我开始这个过程时，我基本上就是画出了
内容过程今天是如何运作的。所以，对于任何创作内容的人来说，你基本上从寻找灵感开始。从历史上看，最难的事情不仅仅是对于那些第一次尝试创作内容的人，
而是对任何人，我实际上会说尤其是创作者，是找到感觉新颖有趣的想法，而不是感觉像对已有内容的疲惫复读，这真的很难。所以第一步是找到
一个想法。第二步，或者说1B，如果这个想法与亲身经历相关，你觉得对这个想法完全了解，那么你可以跳过研究步骤。但对于很多想法，你需要研究。然后接下来
下一步，你要把所有想法都倒在纸上，就像围绕这个主题进行思想的呕吐。之后再确定你想要的锚定格式，比如是长篇网站文章、LinkedIn还是新闻通讯等。
然后你写出内容，接着审阅草稿，进行修改，经历编辑过程，发布出去。之后，正如Gary V在谈论内容金字塔时提到的，你拿锚定内容，把它拆分成微内容，分发到所有社交媒体平台或人们消费内容的平台上。
这就是内容创作的方式，无论是视频还是写作都是如此。我一开始就以此为例，说明今天的情况是这样的。那么，AI在这个流程中应该放在哪里？是应该由AI来主导，还是让AI担任副驾驶？
我想在这里暂停一下，因为我们抛开内容不谈。这正是我告诉每个人在试图弄清楚如何在日常工作或公司中应用AI时要经历的过程。流程优先的方法是将AI融入系统最可行的方式。所以我真的会把它写下来，然后做出决定，比如人类副驾驶自动化。
我推荐的另一件事是，不要根据你当前的限制来规划现在的工作流程，而是设想在没有限制的理想情况下你会怎么做。在没有限制的情况下，你当然会把所有内容切成多频道的微内容。
在没有限制的情况下，你当然会有一个研究员一直在寻找和挖掘想法。所以我认为这两点，写出你的工作流程，以及去除你设计流程时现有的限制，都非常重要。
我们有一期节目邀请了Suzie的CEO Matt，他在他的营销团队中就是这样做的。他拿着一个通话记录，问自己：我能从中提取多少东西？不是问我的团队能提取多少，而是理论上能提取多少。然后他就开始，你知道，从一份内容中衍生出一百个不同的东西。
完全同意。是的，百分之百。我们在与公司和客户进行流程映射的过程中发现，首先，你最终会意识到，即使不考虑使用AI，也能发现很多效率提升点，因为大多数人以前都没有真正做过流程映射，AI只是促使他们去做的动力，然后他们就在流程中发现了所有浪费的地方。
所以，我完全同意这一点，这虽然是件不起眼的事，但如果不从这里开始，我真的不知道你如何重新构想你的工作。这也是为什么当我们谈论AI导致的失业等问题时，我能够做到这一点的唯一原因是我已经做过数千次内容创作的过程。
这向你展示了成为主题专家和拥有垂直专业知识的重要性。至少目前，这种知识确实很需要，否则你无法重新构想工作。好，我基本上就拿这个，然后下一步在流程中，假设没有限制，重建整个系统。
所以，结果就出现了这个叫做内容机器的东西。我会让你看看它是如何运作的，就像可视化呈现一下，然后我会带你看看我实际运行这台机器的过程。基本上，内容机器就是这样工作的。第一步叫做‘神谕’。
整个想法是，内容机器，它只是一个技能目录，一个插件，你可以通过CLI或Claude Coder Co-work来操作，它连接了我10x的所有记录系统，比如我的Slack、Notion、会议笔记、Linear、Git、Gmail，它连接了所有这些。
基本上发生的是，‘神谕’会扫描我所在的所有渠道过去7天的信息，并排出一个短列表，列出它认为好的内容点子。它有一个完整的评分系统，定义什么是好的内容点子。比如，如果有故事或趣闻相关，就加分；如果有强烈观点，就加分；如果有具体例子，就加分。
所以，基本上我每天会收到15个内容点子。其中一半来自‘神谕’查看我的内部系统，另一半则是进行所谓的‘互联网阅读’，我给内容机器提供了一份我在X、LinkedIn上关注的账户以及我常去的网站的列表，它会去查看这些人过去7天发布的所有内容，并把它们作为点子分享出来。
所以，比如你是我互联网阅读器中的一个人，它会查看你过去7天发布的所有内容，当它认为有好的内容点子，比如适合我引用转发或回复你的帖子，它就会把这个点子列入清单。这就是流程的第一步。
仅此一项可能就是整个系统中最有帮助的部分。回到前面的观点，即使你认为AI会产生AI垃圾内容，你不想让它起草内容，但仅仅帮你从空白页走到具体想法，我认为这大大降低了摩擦，你实际上会养成创作的习惯。好，然后你选择一个想法，接着进入所谓的‘面试小组’。
我有六位世界级的采访者，我把他们各自的技巧都编码成了技能，像蒂姆·费里斯、乔·罗根、迈克尔·巴巴罗、芭芭拉·沃尔特斯、霍华德·斯特恩，他们会一个接一个地就这个话题向你提问，直到
他们觉得已经获取了足够的信息来创作一条内容。还有一点我要补充的是，从Oracle直接到采访小组。如果是一个话题，我会在克劳德里面给你演示一下，但如果你选了一个你觉得自己还没有完全掌握信息的话题，你可以运行研究助手，它会给你一份关于这个话题的完整简报。所以，
好，我们经过采访小组。基本上，我做的就是对着WhisperFlow把所有的回答都口述成文本。然后它用我的声音来起草。所以，这个内容机器的运作方式就是，基本上整个过程，就像所有这些
步骤，都存在于内容机器的仓库里，我们团队的每个人电脑上都有这个仓库。但是，我们每个人都有各自的个人文件夹，里面编码了我们的声音、风格指南，还有我们想要从中获取想法的
来源。所以，当一段声音真正被起草，或者说当一条内容真正被起草时，实际上它是进入了我特定的声音和风格指南文件，然后用那个来创作内容。所以，
为了让你看看那是什么样子。我的风格指南在这里，你知道，这是亚历克斯是谁，这是他在公司里的角色，这些是他想要推广的自有资产，这些是他的主要内容锚点类型，这些是他的关键
整合，这些是他关注的社交账号。你看克莱尔在这里，你知道，那些给企业提供具体视角的人。所以，这是第一点，然后第二点是声音指南。这个基本上就是
当我启动内容机器时，它研究了。所以，我所有表现最好的X帖子和LinkedIn帖子都被研究了，有执行摘要，包括声音和语气、钩子公式、内容结构、布局模式、话题类别。所以，这
分解了我有史以来表现最好的前10条X帖子，我表现最好的LinkedIn帖子，我的核心DNA，我的第一条规则，那就是像给朋友发短信一样写作，然后还有我使用的语言的例子，
自嘲式的自信。就像，它真的深入到了这个文件里。就像，这就是我的完整声音编码。然后，我们一会儿会说到，但整个过程的另一个真正重要的部分是
当内容机器为我起草一条内容时，我会给它反馈，它会从反馈中形成一个强化循环。所以，内容机器里的另一个文件是内容教训的markdown文件。
它包含了我过去在起草内容时说过它搞砸的所有事情。它把这些记录为教训。所以，关于语气，当我说语气不对的时候，结构和流程，当那不对的时候。所以，它会
在编辑一条内容时总是检查内容教训markdown，以确保它不再犯同样的错误。
会就最终内容给它反馈。一旦全部完成，我就说，“这个可以了。这个可以发布了。”基本上会启动一个工作，作为这些链条技能的一部分，这就是教训循环。
教训循环就是，“让我看看我们提供给亚历克斯的原始内容和新的内容之间的差异。我们能从中提取出哪些可抽象的教训？”
然后我们问亚历克斯，“你希望这些教训被添加到教训文件里吗？”如果他说是，我们就添加进去。所以，这就是它的运作方式。然后为了带你走完整个过程，我可以
在实践中展示给你看。这就是我的声音是如何被起草的。然后下一步是，我已经分享了我选了一个想法。我在采访小组的访谈中把所有关于这个想法的想法都口述成了文本。然后我选择，比如我想创建一个
LinkedIn帖子。它用我的声音起草，使用我的风格指南、我的声音markdown文件和我的内容教训markdown文件。一旦草稿完成，它会经过作者委员会。所以，类似于我创建的六个采访者角色，
我创建了六个作者角色。就像大卫·佩雷尔、肖恩·普里、摩根·豪塞尔，还有那个AI垃圾内容过敏者。他们会阅读内容，并给它打分，1到10分。如果总分低于
9分（满分10分），它会运行修订循环，直到得10分（满分10分）。然后完成。一旦内容完成，然后我可以重新利用和分发，这意味着有一个步骤，我可以说，我想
重新利用这个。内容机器会问，你想把它重新利用成什么？我可以说三条短推文，两篇长LinkedIn帖子，它会去查看我过去在不同帖子类型中的写作格式，
然后用那种风格来写。
我觉得，这其实反映了几个问题。第一，你要梳理自己的工作流程。第二，有了AI，你基本可以引入一个专家团队，而不需要真的去请一帮专家。所以，在理想情况下，我希望能被最顶尖的人采访。但你猜怎么着？你可以通过流程来近似实现这一点。我觉得，在搭建这个流程的过程中，找到合适的反馈循环，如何迭代优化，这很关键。
因为你能处理非结构化数据的输入和输出，这是以前做不到的，这真的很有用。而且，AI是多模态的，我指的不只是图像到文本，或者文本到语音，语音到文本，而是像从短文本到更短的文本，或者从短文本到长文本。所以，利用LLM的这些不同特性，我觉得这个用例就很好了。
（音乐）本期节目由Customer.io赞助。你来这里是因为你更想用AI而不是谈论AI。有了Customer.io，你只需描述你想构建的营销活动，AI代理就会为你创建受众、消息和时机。你审核一下，做任何修改，然后发布。不用再花几个小时去拼接各种工具和工作流，你可以专注于真正推动增长的工作。每个活动都跟结果挂钩，这样你就能看到哪些有效，下一步该怎么做。超过9000个品牌使用Customer.io，把已有的数据转化为客户记得的消息。今天就访问customer.io/howiai试试吧。Customer.io，让每条消息都发挥更大影响力。我确实在开始前告诉过你，我读过你的帖子，写得相当不错。所以，它们看起来不像垃圾内容，但现场证明一下，现在就做。我们怎么开始这个过程呢？
让我打开我的Claude，我会给你看一个例子，看看它已经是怎么跑的，然后我们现场再试一次。如果这弄得一团糟，我很乐意自嘲一下。好了，基本上我们现在看到的是内容机器在运行。为了让你看得更清楚，这可能会有所帮助：内容机器以插件形式存在于我们内部的Claude（10X）中，基本上每个人都把它添加到自己的机器里。每当我在Git上推送更新，大家就能直接从这里自动更新。所以，我试着想一些让公司里非技术人员也能容易理解的东西，以便他们受益于这些更新。我等会儿再谈这个，比如如何与公司里的每个人分享，让我们更接近那一步——我认为Sendbird的CEO也经历过类似的过程，你跟他聊过，我们怎么朝那个方向靠近。但先让我回到这个话题。基本上，这个系统首先查看我的来源、内部来源，然后指出一些热点想法。比如这个单一玩家对多玩家AI框架，我们经常讨论。我跟一家银行的某个人聊过，他们与麦肯锡合作，麦肯锡给了他们一个想法，说这需要6个月时间构建。他说他用Claude code在一周内就重建了。我在销售电话里说，我可能是世界上最差的销售员，这听起来挺有趣的。我在卖完Morning Brew后，我对电话里的某人说，我很痛苦。那是个不错的内容热点。所以，你可以看到它真的抓住了具体故事，然后从网络阅读器，它从我在个人资料文件里给的来源中提取。所以，一个是，你知道，亚马逊投了十亿美元在FDE上，Aaron Levie和Ethan Mollick在争论FDE是不是每个企业问题的解决方案，而另一些人说，现在人人都能构建，但交付才是难题。然后我会选择我真正想扩展的内容热点。顺便说一句，这里内容机器还有另一个功能：我要选择一个想法来扩展成一篇内容。这里有几个想法我觉得值得扩展。所以，内容机器的一部分是，当公司里每个人第一次设置它时，会创建一个“宝库”，这个宝库就是一个Notion数据库，Oracle生成的每个想法，即使你不用，也会添加到这个宝库里。所以，你以后可以去那里拉出想法。好了，我选了热点13。我觉得热点13很有趣。Aaron Levie说FDE是上帝给地球最好的礼物。Mollick则说，这不会解决所有问题。所以我选了它，想对这个话题做更多研究，比如围绕FDE有哪些不同的论点？为什么Aaron和Ethan的观点不同？然后研究步骤就开始了。你可以看到，基本上为我创建了一个研究简报，包括他们的观点、已经说过的话、我可以采取哪些潜在的逆向或新颖的角度、有哪些我应该尝试回答的开放性问题。所以我事先读了这个。我也可以在采访过程中，如果我觉得这些有很好的引语，我也可以把它们纳入我的回答。然后我就进去，采访开始了。哦，我忘了Larry King也在这里。所以，让Larry King来：Levie说FDE会赢，因为部署代理比人们想的更技术化。Mollick说他们会失望，因为真正的问题是组织结构和技术专长，而不是代码。他还说：“你说他们俩都对。这是他们遗漏的地方。”那么，一两句话，他们遗漏了什么？我提供我的想法，比如FDE是不是解决所有问题的办法？我为什么同意或不同意Aaron和Ethan？
然后后续的问题就顺着我的回答往下问。于是它现在问：“面试小组真的被训练得尽可能从我身上挖掘具体细节和实例。”就像蒂姆·费里斯那样问：“给我讲讲那个特别让人头疼的例子，就是你的团队在技术上完美搞定的那次。”于是它让我讲一个客户案例，我就讲了。我们就这样进行了，我被问了五个问题。然后它说：“面试结束，声音和教训已经锁定。”
接下来，它会查看我的内容经验和声音的MD文件，然后生成LinkedIn草稿。这里，我关注的两个最聪明的人刚刚公开对AI领域最热门的工作发表了不同意见。他们俩都对，而问题恰恰就在这。顺便说一句，如果让我对这条内容提反馈，我会说：“这感觉有点像AI那种尴尬风格。他们俩都对，这种感叹号、破折号之类的是最新的套路。”所以我会给出反馈，并说把这加到内容经验里。
比如，我其中一个回答是：“公司需要做什么才能为AI转型的成功奠定基础？”它直接用了我的原话，就像说：“所以，如果你要为AI转型配备人员，你需要这些。”它写的多半不垃圾的原因之一，基本上是我训练它只用我的话。所以，我觉得这也是很重要的一点，整个内容机器的基石在于，我和面试小组的对话被转化成一个巨大的Markdown转录文件，而转录文件应该只包含使用的词语，除了可能的开头和结尾。而写手的职责几乎就像塑造内容的黏土，而不是发明全新的东西。
而且，在我看来，内容机器真的产生垃圾内容，唯一的情况更像是表明分享想法的人没有在面试阶段分享足够好的想法，而不是AI写作很烂。
嗯，所以你的意思是，我们其实就是垃圾的源头。
这就是我的看法，AI垃圾内容搞笑的地方在于，人们把矛头指向自己，说：“我不够聪明。”然后，它还会做另一件事，我最近刚把它加为一条内容经验，就是：“开始给我更多开头的例子，因为我想能够选择和比较。”所以它会提供开头和结尾。那我在这里会怎么做呢？哦，它甚至没运行作者委员会。是的，那我们就直接运行一下。
现在它会做什么呢？它已经有了草稿，也有了开头和结尾，它会运行编辑委员会。如果评分超过9分（满分10分），它就会原样给我。如果不到，它就会进行修改循环。然后我拿到后，会像刚才我给你反馈那样，比如哪里有点俗气，我会检查一遍，确保这些反馈都加进内容经验的Markdown文件里，然后我会做最后的修改，然后发布。
然后，我的观点是，这也是我想加入内容机器的一点，目前内容机器在我运行预言机时，不会拉取以前应该考虑重新利用的内容。那应该是我每天运行的一部分。所以，看，它们现在都在打分，我已经能看出不会到9分，所以它们会进行完整的修改循环。
天哪，我喜欢这个。然后你会实时看到这个过程。
是的，所以就像我们聊完，我会立刻把这个发布出去。
那么，我想说的是，可能在我们结束这个流程之后，你其实已经给我们展示了从发现好点子，到通过我们的朋友希拉里·格瑞德利，用Yappers API提取所有好点子，再到用我们的声音塑造内容，获得关键反馈然后发布的全流程。但你也提到，这并不全是AI，你还有团队，你还在改变团队的行为，让他们都接受这种新的内容创作模式。那你能不能给我们讲讲你的内容机器里非AI的部分，以及你们公司在尝试的一些事情？
所以，实际上，这个内容机器首先，我不想声称自己是员工倡导的发明者。这已经存在很长时间了，但我只是觉得互联网和其上的平台让它得以实现，而我认为企业还没有跟上，或者他们太担心给公司每个人一个扩音器的风险，以至于最终没有去做。所以，我第一次测试这个是在我的一家公司……
其他公司叫Storyarb，我们搞了个活动叫“占领互联网”，想法是搞个六到八周的活动。Storyarb的每个人都要发领英，或者不是必须，但鼓励他们发，而且有机会赢钱。
我觉得赢家能拿五千美金。唯一规则是你创作的内容得有50%是关于Storyarb的。结果这给公司带来了很多流量。
在举办“占领互联网”的那个季度，它带来了我们40%的入站线索，还为招聘带来了大量顶层漏斗。所以我就知道，只要有机会，我以后还会这么干。
所以我们昨天刚启动了10X的类似活动。我来分享下具体细节。它叫10X创作者杯，是一个月的挑战，让
10X的每个人都发帖。玩法就是你在领英或X上发帖，然后我们内部有个Slack频道叫“回帖侠”，每个人都能看到大家的帖子在整个创作者杯期间。
规则是每发一次帖得10分，每次评论公司同事的帖子得3分。每周我和联合创始人会选出本周最佳帖子，
得主能加50分。还有每周游戏和月度游戏。重点是鼓励大家发帖，而不是单纯比曝光量，免得一个人
曝光量爆表。我们不想让人觉得没机会。我们还希望让大家都觉得有参与感，只要玩就有收获。所以
举个例子，这周的周游戏叫“满堂红”，就是如果公司至少70%的人这周都发一次帖，我们就解锁第一周的奖品，每个人都能拿一张
彩票，然后抽一个人赢几百美金。所以这周我们就发5000美金奖金。但有趣的是，我们之前聊过这个。我说“10X，我们是在
地狱模式玩游戏。”你会说你们是在诚信模式玩吗？对，我觉得差不多。10X是完全白手起家的，这要求我们在某些方面得有创意。其中之一就是
我们确实有世界上最好的工程师，我合作过最好的。原因有几个。但我们还没有OpenAI或Anthropic那样的实验室声望。而且因为我们没融到
大笔资金，我们也没有上TechCrunch或被顶级投资人提及的那种曝光度。所以问题就来了，在没这些风险投资公司优势的情况下，怎么吸引顶尖人才？
我的观点是，你得让顶尖人才展示而不是光说他们做的酷工作。所以对我来说，就算10X创作者杯不给我们带来任何业务线索，
如果它只是让更多工程师知道10X并申请加入，理想情况下，如果这个活动能招到一个工程师，那么付出去的5000美元就
值了不知多少倍，因为想想你付给猎头公司招一个工程师要多少钱，这就完全值了。所以，对，我就是相信我们应该利用白手起家这一点，就是
要有黑马心态，用游击营销，大家团结一致，给10X营造一种光环。
作为另一个白手起家的创始人，我也在靠分销作为优势，我完全同意。我觉得还有一点，我们低估了员工价值主张，比如我们其实鼓励你建立自己的平台。很多公司都很短视，因为我听有些CEO说，“我可不想让那个人吹嘘自己多厉害，
因为那样会有人来挖他。”
对。
我会说，那正是让他们离开公司的头号原因，就是他们不能谈论自己做的所有酷事，不能建立自己的个人品牌。所以我觉得那完全
完全正确。而且，我也喜欢看到另一个白手起家的创始人这么做。我说，不是地狱模式，也许地狱模式，但绝对是诚信模式。
完全同意。而且我还在想，就算像Anthropic，他们在网上做得好的地方就是，不管是有意还是无意，他们基本上是员工网红。比如你想想
围绕着Cloud Code和Co-work的每个人，不管是Tariq、Boris还是Felix，对吧？他们现在就是品牌的延伸，我因为他们在谈论产品而不是公司本身，所以更信任他们的产品。
完全同意，太棒了。亚历克斯，这次对话真的让我受益匪浅，给了我很多灵感。嗯，我也有一个类似的内容引擎，叫Open Claw，它的名字是马克斯，不过你懂的，大同小异。那么，我很想以一个快速问答环节来结束，然后你就可以离开了。第一个问题，你曾说你合作的都是世界上最优秀的工程师，至少是那些你合作过的。那你认为，现在什么样的人才算得上优秀的工程师？
嗯，我觉得是那些能够深入理解系统的人，那些工程师一直都很出色的根本特质，但同时他们又很灵活，能完全拥抱让工作流程变得智能化的变化。我觉得，
有很多非常年轻的工程师，他们完全被AI迷住了，但缺乏那种资深或高级工程师所拥有的知识基础。而我又觉得，有很多资深工程师，他们不够灵活，无法改变自己的工作方式。
我还想到了一点，就是“前线部署工程师”这个概念比以往任何时候都重要，因为AI转型只能通过理解企业的具体背景来实现。嗯，所以这部分就是这样，另一部分我觉得世界上最优秀的工程师自己也想长远发展，他们相信自己的能力，这也是为什么我们给工程师的薪酬是销售人员的10倍。
人们觉得我们疯了，但我的想法是，我想自我筛选那些愿意赌自己能力的人。
我同意。你知道我说过多少次让项目经理和工程师拿浮动薪酬吗？说了很久了。我觉得这样最好。
这确实很不可思议，而且我们依然会收到很多人的质疑，你看，确实有取舍，但我们都考虑过了，这让我们所有员工都保持在技术前沿，因为他们获得杠杆的方式就是理解技术的可能性。
嗯，我要为你的员工们点赞。我们之前也请过两位10倍薪酬的嘉宾，都很棒，你可以看看和CJ还有JJ的那两集。那么，你会雇佣那些名字不是两个字母的人吗？
我正要说呢，我真的得改名叫AJ了。我搞乱了10倍嘉宾的节奏。
好吧，我妻子名字缩写是EJ，所以如果你需要团队里多个J字头的人，我们可以安排。好的，第二个问题，你给我们看了你的创作过程。我们看到了你和JJ的合作，和CJ的编程。那么，你自己个人有什么用例吗？就是你个人生活中觉得非常特别的一个AI用例？
嗯，我妻子有一段时间在找工作。她在科技行业工作，找工作有一阵子了，我觉得我给她建的一个挺有趣的用例是，招聘过程很残酷，找到合适的工作也很残酷。但我觉得我们处于这样一个时代，就像人们一直在说的，当我们在做Morning Brew的时候，有人会做出一对一的通讯稿。就像新闻一样，每个人都有自己的定制通讯。基本上我建的是一个为她定制的招聘板，她每天都会收到一封邮件，里面有10个根据她之前的职位、领英资料和她的求职目标筛选并评分的工作，然后她可以点击邮件里的申请按钮，它会自动填充初始申请信息。这就是一个具体的用例。
另一个我觉得比较经典的用例是做一本定制的儿童书。我们家里有个11个半月大的宝宝，你知道，想到我们可爱的布鲁克能有和她家人相关的故事，对我来说真是太酷了。
我很喜欢。你得加入我们的“How I AI”父母圆桌会议，因为我们有很多好用的用例。好了，最后一个问题，我问每个人的，当你的AI神谕创意委员会给你一堆垃圾内容时，你的提示技巧是什么？你会生气吗？还是会贿赂它？
诚实说，我可能会……这取决于我有多沮丧，以及我有多少时间。
我喜欢你慌张的样子。你好像在说，哦哦，我该说实话吗？
不，不，不。所以要么我就直接说，算了，我自己手写算了。我觉得那是我通常的做法，我会想，去它的，这花的时间不值当，我自己写吧。
手工来做。或者我也会认真投入，花大量时间，觉得这不行。这些都是这些东西不行的地方。我敢肯定这些内容经验已经讲过了。为什么
这没被当成我已经教过的内容经验呢？所以我真的应该对它好一点，毕竟AI大佬总有一天会当我的老板，但说实话，我有时候对它挺凶的。
>> 所以经典的就是，不，你怎么能这样？
>> [笑声]
>> 我还没问过这个。
>> Alex，这真的很有帮助。我要偷走这些想法，这也是我搞这些采访的秘密原因。谢谢你分享给我们和我们的观众。我们在哪里能找到你，怎么联系你？
>> 我在X上是Business Barista，LinkedIn上是Alex Lieberman，我们公司叫10X。所以如果你是大公司需要AI转型帮助，就去10x.co找我们。
>> 如果你是优秀的工程师，Alex在招人。
>> 是的。
>> 全部。
>> 真的全部。
>> 据内容机器说，你在招所有人。
>> 没错。
>> 感谢来到How I AI。
>> 非常感谢。
>> 感谢观看。如果你喜欢这个节目，请在YouTube上点赞订阅，或者更好的是，留下评论告诉我们你的想法。你也可以在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你最喜欢的
播客应用上找到这个播客。请考虑给我们评分和评论，这能帮助其他人发现这个节目。你可以在howiaipod.com上看到我们所有的剧集并了解更多信息。下次见。